white house chief of staff mark meadows
joins us now good morning mr meadows
thanks for being with us i want to get
to the executive order
sure in a moment but i want to start as
ben reported in his piece the pen the
president said again
that he's not sure this election can be
honest
why does the president refuse to commit
to a peaceful transfer of power
well i think he commits to a peaceful
transfer as long as it's
it's a fair election and i think that
even the lead
up into this was talking about that very
subject we now know that we have a
department of justice investigation into
ballots that were discarded
from veterans in pennsylvania that's
very troubling anyone who sends in a
ballot
to find them discarded what we want to
make sure is that every vote counts
but that only the vote from one voter
to the ballot box is what gets counted
and
nothing less nothing more and so that's
what he's referring to that's what we're
committed to we're seeing some very
problematic rulings by judges
in certain states across the country
hopefully we'll be able to make sure
that
this election goes off like every other
election and that the winner on november
3rd will will certainly be the new
president sworn in
on january 20. the case in pennsylvania
you refer to
involves just nine ballots and according
to the department of justice they did
not specify any particular crime or
allege
any wrongdoing at this point but the
president continues to say the november
elections will be
rigged what evidence if any does he have
and what does the white house plan to do
about it
well to suggest that an investigation
that just got
uh going in the last 24 hours has not
found any wrongdoing would be
a rush to judgment that you wouldn't
want to make i wouldn't want to make
but we have reports but we have reports
from the washington post during the
primary
of over five hundred thousand ballots
that were problematic in the primaries
and so
uh that's a substantially larger number
that we look at
should we allow votes to come in and be
counted uh
a week after november 3rd i don't
believe so
that's what we're talking about let's
make sure that the systems that we've
had in place
for decades indeed centuries are the
same systems we have in place now
but we have activist judges trying to
change the election laws
and those are not going through the
legislature that's very problematic for
the american people
very problematic for the president mr
meadows the president has said if he
loses the election will have been raped
well i i think what he looks at is is
just like
every candidate that runs hillary
clinton before
hillary clinton 40 years out still
doesn't believe that she lost the
election
she's also calling on joe biden to not
concede the election
you know what is that if if we're
looking four years later
uh where they're saying that this
president is not their president
every candidate that runs believes that
they're running the right election
i can tell you we're doing what it takes
we're out each and every day
making our case to the american people
we believe he'll win on november 3rd
and with a free and fair election i
believe he'll win right but
as we as as ben tracy pointed out in the
piece your own fbi director says
he has seen no evidence of of widespread
of voter fraud by mail or otherwise well
with all due respect to director ray he
has a hard time finding
emails in his own fbi uh let alone of
figuring out whether there's
any kind of voter fraud this is a very
different case the rules are being
changed and so what
what i'm suggesting is perhaps he can
drill down on the investigation that
just started
others that we're seeing in north
carolina and other places
where multiple ballots duplicate ballots
are being sent out
perhaps he needs to get involved on the
ground and he would change his testimony
on capitol hill
mr meadows yesterday the president as we
reported signed a healthcare executive
order
to protect patients with pre-existing
conditions
but it doesn't explain how the president
intends to do that
how will that happen well it's just try
uh trying primarily
to make sure that any uh insurance
company if they've got someone covered
to make sure that they can't increase
the premiums uh and and essentially
uh price that person out of out of
coverage just because they happen to
to get sick or have a pre-existing
condition
additionally that is is law right now
but that codification yesterday said
it's the official policy
of president trump to make sure that any
legislation
whether it's new legislation moving
forward whether it's executive orders or
anything else
that pre-existings will always be uh
protected under a trump administration
yeah but as you point out
the affordable care act actually already
covers that although you
well but it's going through the courts
right now so i think you're trying
but there was one other key thing that
happened yesterday that you're not
covering
the president actually uh mentioned
and is starting in october to send out
discount cards for uh
co-pays to 33 million seniors
in october and november they will be
receiving a card
where they get to have 200 credit to
help with co-pays it's the first time
that money went from big pharma's pocket
into the pocket of american seniors and
that it was big news yesterday
mark meadows thank you very much for
being with us this morning we appreciate
it
thank you